[موسيقى]
اذا مع تضارب الارقام بشان اعداد الضحايا
منذ اندلاع المواجهات في الخامس عشر من
ابريل اليكم لمحه عامه عن خريطه الوضع
ميدانيا فبحسب مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه
للامم المتحده اوتشا فان الاشتباكات
العنيفه تمركزت في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وكذلك في بحر اما في الفاشر
بولايه شمال دارفور فقد شهدت اشتباكات
متقطعه بين طرفي الصراع باستخدام الاسلحه
الثقيله والخفيفه هذا وحذرت لجان الاحياء
في ود مدني بولايه الجزيره من اشتباكات
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع على طول
الطريق من الخرطوم الى مدني الذي كان احد
الطرق الرئيسيه التي يستخدمها الفارون من
العاصمه ونتيجه الاشتباكات المستمره ونقص
السلع الاساسيه نزح بين عشره الى عشرين
الف شخص من النساء والاطفال الى دوله تشاد
المجاوره للس ودان وفقا لمفوضيه الامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين رصد مكتب الشؤون
الانسانيه بالامم المتحده مقتل 413 شخصا
واصابه ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه اخرين في
الاشتباكات حتى الحادي والعشرين من ابريل
الجاري
وذكر تقرير ايضا للمكتب ان الخرطوم سجلت
اعلى عدد من القتلى
ب132 ثم ولايه شمال كردوفان بخمسه وتسعين
قتيلا وشمال دارفور بواحد وستين قتيلا ومع
استمرار الاقتتال لا يزال عدد القتلى
مرشحا للزياده
اقتلام المطر
[تصفيق]
وعلى صعيد الجهود الدوليه والاقليميه بحث
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان مع مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل بحث الجهود
المبذوله لوقف التصعيد العسكري بين طرفي
النزاع وانهاء العنف في السودان بالاضافه
الى توفير الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين
السودانيين والمقيمين مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي مشاهدينا
كشف عن توافق سعودي اوروبي على العمل
الجماعي من اجل وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان
ذكر قائد قوات الدعم السريع في السودان
محمد حمدان دقلو انه اكد لمنسق سياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي التزام قوته
المطلق بالهدنه الانسانيه المعلنه مضيفا
ان قوته مستعده لتقديم ما يلزم من تسهيلات
تساعد المواطنين والجاليات الاجنبيه على
المرور الى اماكن امنه حيث اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن بدء عمليه اجلاء
سريعه لمواطنيها كذلك ايضا لطاقمها
الدبلوماسي بعد ان دخلت المعارك العنيفه
اسبوعها الثاني والفتاه الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الى ان العمليه ستشمل ايضا مواطنين
اوروبيين واخرين يتبعون دولا حليفه مؤكده
انها حصلت على ضمانات من طرفي الصراع في
السودان لتامين عمليه الاجلاء
تبادل الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الاتهامات باطلاق النار اثناء عمليه اجلاء
رعايه فرنسيين ما اسفر عن اصابه احدهم
وذكر الجيش السوداني في بيان ان عناصر من
الدعم السريع اعتدت على السفير الماليزي
والبعث القطري المتوجهه الى بورتسودان كما
تعرض موكب السفاره الفرنسيه لاطلاق النار
ما ادى الى عودتهم وتعطيل عمليه الاجلاء
فالمقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان
ان طائرات الجيش هي التي استهدفت موكب
السفاره الفرنسيه
وشددت الدعم السريع على التزامها بالهدنه
وتسهيل حركه الرعايه الاجانب لمناطق
الاجلاب هذا وقال متحدث باسم قوات الدعم
السريع في السودان ان قواته نفذ الظهر
الاحد عمليه اجلاء جريحين من الرعايه
اليونانيين الى مقر السفاره الفرنسيه وذلك
بعد ان تعرضا لغاره من طيران الجيش
السوداني حسب ما جاء على لسان
المتحدث باسم الدعم السريع اما بالنسبه
لمصر مع تصاعد الاضطرابات في السودان فقد
اعلنت وزاره خارجيتها اصابه احد اعضاء
السفاره في الخرطوم بطلق الناري واكدت ان
هذا الحادث يؤكد مره اخرى على ضروره توقي
اقصى درجات الحذر حفاظا على سلامه
المواطنين والدبلوماسيين ودعت الخارجيه
المصريه المواطنين المصريين الموجودين
خارج الخرطوم الى التوجه الى مدينتي حلفا
وبورتسودان تمهيدا لاجلائهم هذا وقالت
مصادر العربيه ان مصر ستمنح تاشيره دخول
للرعايه الاجانب القادمين من السودان
واضافت المصادر ايضا
ان اليونان وقبرص تونسيقاني مع القاهره
لاجلاء رعايهما من السوداني ايضا
اذا الصحه العالميه مشاهدينا الكرام كما
يظهر في الخبل الخبر العاجل اسفل
الشاشه
نتابعه الان
قبل قليل الهلال الاحمر السوداني اولا قال
بانه لا توجد مصادر امنه او موثوقه
للاتصالات كذلك ايضا في الاخبار العاجله
التي تاتينا من السودان التي تعيش اليوم
السابع في هذا الاحتراب بين القوات الدعم
السريع وايضا الجيش السوداني الصحه
العالميه تقول بان المؤسسات الصحيه في
السودان تعرضت
لهجمات كما يظهر طبعا امامنا في الاخبار
العاجله التي نستعرضها الان معكم تقول بان
المؤسسات الصحيه في السودان تعرضت لهجمات
شرسه ويجب ان تنتهي الان قالت بانه لا
ينبغي ان يكون مقدم الرعايه ومن يحتاجون
اليها هدفا للهجمات في السودان قبل ذلك
الهلال الاحمر السوداني كان قد تحدث
للعربيه بان هناك
معوقات يواجهونها في الكثير من المناطق
مباشره الى العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس يلتحق
بنا من هناك الصحه والمحلل السياسي
السوداني محمد الاسباط
السيد محمد اهلا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
في البدايه اريد ان
اسالك عن من قالته صح العالميه قبل قليل
بانها تتعرض لهجمات شرسه ويجب ان تنتهي
هذه الهجمات الان كيف سيتم التعامل مع هذه
التحذيرات في ظل وضع انساني وصحي صعب
ويوصف بالخطير في السودان الان
ننتقل لك ولمشاهدين
في وجع الامر ان المرتبه الصحيه في
السودان وفي الخرطوم خصوصا هي اصلا في وضع
كارثي يعني قبل اكثر من 5 ايام من
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه عن الخدمه
بسبب يعني مشكلات خاصه بالكوادر وتعرضها
لاطلاق النار وانقطاع الكهرباء والمياه
والحجمات التي تعرضت لها بعض المستشفيات
من قبل طرفي القتال وبالتالي يعني تاتي
هذه هياته هذا التحذير
لغصل الفترات الفلسفيه في الخرطوم الى
مرحله الخروج الثامن عن الخدمه وهو يعني
هي اخطر مرحله ممكن اتصل لي اليها بلد في
العالم يعني طيب هي قالت لا ينبغي ان يكون
مقدمه الرعايه ومن حتى يحتاج الى هدفا
للهجمات في السودان هل هم فعلا اصبحوا
هدفا للهجمات هدفا لهذه الاشتباكات
لا يعني
نحن مع ما قالته الصحه العالميه الان يعني
في هذه الاخبار العاجله ان كنت تشاهد
الشاشه الان
انا لكن نتعامل مع الوقائع منذ يوم
الاثنين واليوم الثالث للحرب وقعت شظائف
في اكثر من مستشفى في اليوم هاجمت مجموعه
مقاتله بمجموعات المتحاربه مستشفى الشرطه
واستورد عليه
انقطع التيار الكهربائي ولم يكن هنالك
امكانيه لتوفر وقود لاكثر من تسعه
مستشفيات بسبب الحرب يعني هي اساس
المستشفيات والوساره الصحيه والعلاجيه
تعاني مشكلات حقيقيه قبل ان يطلق يطلق
الصحه العالميه هذا النداء الان الوضع
اكثر كارثيه يعني لك ان تتخيل من من تسعه
وخمسين مستشفى ان تكون تعمل فقط تسعه الى
عشره مستشفيات وهنالك 87 مستشفيات تعمل
يعني بالحد الادنى من طاقتها الوضع وفي
بلد تع
اني بكل دقيقه هنالك مريض وهنالك جريح
يحتاج الى
رعايه ويمكن الحديث انه الان نحن نتحدث
فقط عن العاصمه الخرطوم سيد محمد حسب
معلوماتك
لا هناك
[موسيقى]
ابقى معنا سيد محمد سعود اليك في ثنايا
هذه التغطيه
[موسيقى]
قبل ان نكمل المشاهدين دعونا نذكر
بالتصريحات التي ادلى بها رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي السوداني الفريق عبد
الفتاح البرهان للعربيه والتي اكد فيها ان
كل مطارات السودان تحت سياده الجيش
السوداني باستثناء مطري الخرطوم ونيال
البرهان اتهم قوات الدعم السريع بتفتيش
المنازل ومصادره الاموال والاعتداء على
البعثات الدبلوماسيه مشيرا الى ان هذه
القوات تنتشر في الاحياء السكنيه
والمجمعات الخدميه
كل المطارات تحته الجيش مطار الخرطوم في
مطار نياله في اشكاليه بقيه بطارات
السودان كلها تحت سيطره الدوله انا طبعا
رعايه الدول اصابهم الحلاوه واصابهم الخوف
من الممارسات مجموعات الدعم السريعه
الممتلئه داخل سكنيه وهي تفتش المنازل
وتصادر الاموال وتعتدي على الدبلوماسيه
دون اي مراعه لح
رمه المواطنين
الان هذه المجموعات منتشره داخل حياه
السكنيه داخل المجمعات الخدميه وتقوم
بافعاله الخوف والهلع وال
روح في المقابل كشف محمد حمدان دقلو حماتي
قائد قوات الدعم السريع في تصريحاته
للعربيه انه متواجد في الخرطوم برفقه
مقاتله حيث يحرص على توجيههم في المعارك
وتتبع تطورات الاشتباكات
لكن هو موجود موجود
انا
ارد عليه كلام
نشرت على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي او نشر
فيديو يظهر قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
وهو يرتدي زين عسكريا ويحمل سلاحا حيث يعد
الظهور الاول له منذ بدء الاشتباكات في
السودان
اكد نائب رئيس الوزراء البريطاني اوليفر
دودن على وزير الدفاع انه يعمل الان لدعم
وزاره الخارجيه في دعم الرعايه البريطانيه
المشددا ان الوضع في السودان سريع الوتيره
ومعقد على حد وصفه هذا
لان الوضع في السودان سريع الوتيره ومعقد
اولوياتنا هي دعم الرعايه البريطانيين
ويعمل وزير الدفاع الان لدعم وزاره
الخارجيه لكن لن اعلق لاسباب الامنيه على
الوضع الحالي من حيث التحركات على الارض
من القاهره ينضم الي اللواء معتصم العجب
المحلل العسكري عضو تجمع قدامى المحاربين
السودانيين سياده اللواء مرحبا بك معي على
شاشه العربيه في هذه التغطيه المفتوحه
للاحداث في السودان دعني ابدا معك من
الفيديو الذي نشر على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لوجود الجنرال حميتي على ارض
المعارك في الميدان في العاصمه الخرطوم هل
يمكن ان يكون هذا الفيديو
يعني له رسائل او دلالات معينه يمكن
قراءتها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ومرحب بكم حياك الله والله بالنسبه
للفيديو وهو بنسبه انه الراجل ده كلامه
صحيح يعني هو كان في في المخاطب بتاعته
قبل 24 ساعه تقريبا بيقول انه موجود وسط
جنوده في الميدان يعني
شيء عادي يعني
يعني ما يفتكر انه في فبركه او كده لانه
الراجل اساسا هم الناس بيعتمدوا على
الوجود في الميدان شيء عادي يعني لانه انا
اسالك لماذا لان هناك بعض الفيديوهات مثلا
التي نشرت من قبل قوات الدعم السريع كما
يقول بعض السودانيين على موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او المتابعين للوضع في السودان
بان هذه الفيديوهات سجلت منذ وقت يعني
طويل منذ اكثر من اسبوع وهم ينشرون هذه
الفيديوهات بشكل متقطع وعلى فترات مختلفه
وجاء من ضمنها هذا الفيديو الذي سجل للسيد
حمدتي فانا سالتك في هذا الاطار فقط وما
الذي يعنيه نشره في هذا الوقت عسكريا لا
ما يفتكر يعني وجوده وجوده في الميدان شيء
عادي يعني طيب
الراجل ده بدا اساسا الخدمه العسكريه
بتاعته بداها في في الميدان يعني
واحتضنوا النظام السابق
او
حكومه تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين احتضنته
لانه حل لهم مشاكل في في في دارفور
وحصلت حصلت كانت انتفاضه قويه جدا ايوه في
في دارفور يعني بعد 2003
لما انعجز الجيش
في الفتره او كانت القوات قليله
والطبيعه بتاعه الحرب في في الصحراء
فجندوه هو وجندوه برضو
موسى هلال طيب
وحولوهم لحرس حولوهم لحرس حدود وتاريخ
طويل فهو الراجل ده اساسا بدا في
الميدانها يعني بدا في الميدان بدا مقاتل
وبالتالي موجوده في الميدان غير مستغرب
يمكن لانه اتى الحديث
في ظل هذه
فقط عن التوقيت طيب اريد ان اسال سياده
اللواء معك عن سياده الوان كنت تسمعني
هناك فرق في
وصول الصوت والصوره بيني وبينك لكن اريد
ان اسال عن خريطه الاشتباكات اليوم في
السودان حسب مكتب الامم المتحده الانسان
اوتشاف انه يقول بان هذه الاشتباكات تتركز
في الخرطوم في الخرطوم بحري في الفاشر في
ام درمان وكذلك ايضا في دارفور الى اي مدى
يعني هذه المعلومات دقيقه وهل لا زالت
الاشتباكات على نفس الحده منذ بدايه
الازمه وحتى الان ام لا تغيرت بحسب
المعطيات الجديده ومنها الهدى مثل الهدنه
التي اعلنت بسبب اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب من
الخرطوم
لا حده حده الاشتباكات من اليوم اهداء
اهدا من الايام سبقتها يعني امس كان في
قتال عنيف جدا بالذات في في منطقه في بحري
في
انحاء بحري متفرغه
برضو كان في معارك في شرق النيل اللي هي
برضو امتداد بحريه يعني
زائد الاشتباكات الحاصله في في المنطقه
بتاعت المطار والقياده العامه لكن حده
الاشتباكات اليوم اقل كثير اقل اقل يعني
اقل اقل
على حسب المتابعه
يمكن انت تبعته اليوم
التصريحات والاتهامات المتبادله بين قوات
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع تحديدا في
استهداف البعثات الدبلوماسيه التي تحاول
مغادره السودان منها البعثه
الكل يتهم الاخر بانه هو من نفذ هجمات ضد
هذه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
برايك هل هناك ما يشير الى ان عناصر الدعم
السريع او حتى عناصر قوات الجيش بهذه
الهجمات
فقدت التواصل مع قياداتها هل هذا سيناريو
متوقع
ما يفتكر لانه هو
يعني ما يفتكروا يفقد القياده للطرفين
يعني صعب جدا تقول فقد القياده
كل
الاتصالاتهم
دي موجوده يعني ما في منطقه نائيه او
منطقه بعيده موجوده في في في في وسط
الخرطوم والمسافات بيناتهم يعني في حي ما
في حي سفارات لكن معروفه السفارات كلها في
المنطقه بتاعه العمارات دي عادت السفاره
الامريكيه اللي هي مشت بنت في في سوبا
عموما يعني الاتصال سهل يعني حتى لو
الاتصالات التلفونيه
اللاسلكي مقطوع ممكن حتى لو رسلت احد يعني
المناطق قريبه يعني قريبه للمناطق بتاع
تواجد القران نفسها فما ما في ما في مساله
بتاعت فقد اتصال
طيب بالنسبه للاصابه الحصاله دي بالنسبه
معلش اكمل بالنسبه للاصابه اللي حصلت دي
ترجح يعني لسببين يعني سببين
السبب الاول ممكن في الاشتباكات بيحصل زي
ما بيقولوا يعني تقاطع النيران في خطوط
بتاع التقاطع النيران جات الطلقه دي او
الطلقتين جاءت في عربيه اصابت حد
يعني انه يكون وقع في في كروس في في تقاطع
ما مقصود ممكن تضرب تقاطعات ناريه الحاجه
الثانيه في احتمال يعني انا
السيطره القوات المسلحه ما بتضرب باحساس
دبلوماسيه لا يمكن كويس ولا الدعم السريع
الدعم السريع فمن استهدفها اذا اذا لم يكن
الجيش
موجود طرف طرف ثالث موجود في المعركه دي
الناس لازم تفهم الكلام اللي هو التنظيمات
الجناح المتطرف من تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين
الحركه او ما يسمى بالحركه الاسلامويه
الحركه الاسلاميه في طرف تالي هو اللي
حيكون مستفيد من اللاكن للدعم السريع عنده
غرض في انه يضرب بحساب حيستفيد حاجه من
ضرب باحساد اجنبيه او
القوات المسلحه
لا يمكن فقد اتصال المنطقه زي ما قلت لك
قريبه يعني حتى انت لو فاقد الاتصال ممكن
واضح يمشي بعربيه او برجوله
انا انا برجع هنا في الحاله يقرص خير او
او طرف الثالث هو مستمر في الشغل
واضح جدا شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره
لواء معتصم العجب المحلل العسكري عضو
التجمع قدامى المحاربين السودانيين شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نشير فقط مشاهدينا لهذا الخبر العاجل
الهلال الاحمر السوداني يقول للعربيه او
نعيد التذكير به مره اخرى يطالب بتحيد
المنشات الطبيه عن العمليات
العدائيه الهلال الاحمر السوداني كان قد
تحدث مع العربيه قبل قليل طالبه بتحديد
المنشات الطبيه وايضا كذلك منظمه الصحه
العالميه كما تابعنا ايضا كانت قد يعني
حذرت من انزلاق الوضع في السودان وبان
المؤسسات
الصحيه في السودان تعرضت لهجمات شرسه ويجب
ان تنتهي الان قالت كذلك بان
المؤسسات ايضا الصحيه في السودان تواجه
خطرا نقصا ايضا كذلك في
الادويه وايضا فيما يخص المستشفيات ايضا
كذلك وبان الطواقم لا يجب ان الطبيه لا
يجب ان تكون هدفا للهجمات في السودان
وفي التصريحات للعربيه نفى المستشار الاول
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع فارس النور طرحه
انفسهم كبديل للجيش واكد استعداد الدعم
السريع للاندماج بالجيشي بعد تطهيره من
عصابات سيطره عليه وفق تعبيره
ان الجيش السوداني الان مختطف وابناء
الشعب السوداني وهنا في نقطه مهمه حتى
يعني احنا ما طارحين نفسنا بديل للجيش
السوداني
نحن دايرين نطهر الجيش السوداني من
العصابه التي سيطرت عليه وبعد ذلك الجيش
السوداني هو الاساس لكي نكون جيش قومي نحن
سوف نندمج في الجيش السوداني لكي نكون جيش
رومي يحمي الدستور
يحمل البلاد من الاعداء الخارجيين
هذا هدفنا نحن لسنا بدي
ش المستشار الاول لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
فارس النور اكد ان هدفهم الرئيسي انجازه
التحول الديمقراطي لدوله مدنيه
دخلنا هذه المعركه هدفنا الرئيسي والذي
الان اذا المعركه حتجيب بسبب هذا الهدف هو
انه يتم تسليم السلطه للمدنيين وانسحاب
المكون العسكري من العمليه السياسيه
لايجاد التحول الديموطي لطلبه الطلبه
السوداني
هنالك الان
كتيبه كامله متفرغه من الطرف الاخر ترتدي
زي الدعم السريع لكي تدق السينما بين
الدعم السريع والمجتمع الدولي هم انضربوا
الرصاص على
السفاره الامريكيه هم اعتدوا على
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي
وينضم الينا من الرياض محمود العوته
الكاتب الصحفي السوداني سيد محمود مرحبا
بك معي في هذه التغطيه
الخاصه ومفتوحه على شاشه
العربيه اريد فقط ان اسال في البدايه عن
هذه الاخبار العاجله الرئيس الوزراء
البريطاني يقول بانه يدعو طرفي الصراع في
السودان يتحدث عن البرهان وحميتي الى
تنحيه السلاح جانبا الكثير من الدعوات
الكثير من الوساطات ايضا حتى هذه اللحظه
لكن الدعوه البريطانيه هل يمكن ان تلقى
صدى وتجاوبا قبولا بين طرفي هذه الازمه
[موسيقى]
شكرا على الصدف في قناه العربيه
يمكن دي اول دعوه من
الحكم البريطانيه على مستوى ويمكن ده جاءت
كرده فعل يمكن امس كانت في تظاهره بعض
السودانيين الموجودين في بريطانيا كانوا
بيطالبوا بتدخل سريع لبريطانيا بحكم
العلاقه التاريخيه بين السودان
وبريطانيا يعني
ومد الجسور
وعمل شيء سريع حتى بتدخل يمكن يعني اللي
فهمته تدخل العسكري سريع او الضغط على
المتواجدين الان في الساحه من العسكر اذا
كان الفريق البرهان او الفريق حماكي ولكن
يا اخي انا اعتقد انه الان العلاجي سوف
يكون صعبا انت الان بتشهد اكبر
جلاء لسفارات اجنبيه في السودان لم يحدث
انا اعتقد في التاريخ القديم لم يحدث يعني
كميات كبيره من الرعايه والموظفين
الدبلوماسيين من السودان وهذا يعني هذا
هذا الجلاء يعني ترك فرا
غ قبل الوضع الشان الداخلي ما حيلقى اي
طريقه للتواصل يعني انت الان ما موجود
سفير ما موجود اي جهات اخرى حتى انا سمعته
انه مندوب المتحده سوف يغادر السودان كل
المكاتب والمنظمات الامميه والانسانيه
والحقوقيه اعلنت تعليق عملها في الخرطوم
بانها ايضا ستغادر حتى السفر الامريكيه
على ان التعريف العملاء
لن يكون مفيدا في ظل انه الان
في تصريحات من مسؤول في وزير وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه بيقول انه الصراع هذا
سوف يكون مداه طويلا وليس قصيرا
انا اعتقد انه هذا هذا موضوع كبير جدا
لانه
بحسات الاخرى بدات في بعد
ما الخارجيه الامريكيه
استعداد يعني اجبت خمسه طائرات
يعني لا رعاياهم موظفيها كامله واغلقت
السفاره العمل فيها الرئيس الامريكي
[موسيقى]
لا يعني رعاينا الا ان يعني لكن الامر
يعني اعتقد هل هل تعتقد بان هذا نذير
لتصعيد بعد هذه الهدنه عمليه الاجلاء ايضا
مزيد من الاحتراب في السودان والتفاقم
الوضع الخطير الذي تمر في هذه
الان السودان من 2019 اربع سنوات هنالك
نقاشات وجد السياسي بيزنطي اربع سنوات فما
بالان الان دخلوا في صراع عسكري انا اعتقد
الامر حيكون اصعب اذا كان الان نحن اربع
سنوات ننتظر لتشكيل حكومه ديمقراطيه او
حتى حكومه انتقاليه لتسير الاعمال غير
موجود السوداني اخي الكريم
السياسيه كبيره جدا ودبلوماسيه هيا انت
الراس التنفيذي او الرقص التنفيذي للحكومه
غير موجود
قلي
له وليس وزراء الذي هو على يده تدار كل
الامور التنفيذيه يعني وبالتالي عدم وجود
حكومه في ظل هذا هذا الصراع العسكري
العسكري عدم وجود حكومه مدنيه
كيف القى بظلاله على هذه الازمه
يعني الان انت بتشاهد المشهد صعب
الان كل حد في السودان يفكر او في الخرطوم
بالذات يفكر النزوح من العاصمه وهذاك يعني
كلام خطير انتشرت الفوضى الخلاقه خروج
المفاجئين من السجون حرق المصانع يعني
نعرف في مصانع الان بتعمل بتنتج ادوات
شرعيه يوميه حرقت تم عمليات نهب يعني كل
هذه الاشياء المواطن غير امن حتى يتحرك
عده امتار للذهاب الى
للبغاله او لاي محل تاني حتى يشتري
ملتزماته الان رجعت الادوات التقليديه
نلاحظ انه هنالك وجود ادوات تقليديه للناس
يجلبون المياه من البحر وهي من مياه عكره
هذا وضع انساني سيء جدا يعني هذه المشاهد
كلها هذه ادت الى هذه الفوضى لا توجد
مواصلات حتى ينتقل الناس من الخرطوم الى
الاقاليم الان كل الناس
بيفكر الى مصر القريبه الج
ار القريب او خمسين لذهاب الى مصر ونعتقد
ابقى معي نبقى معي ساعود اليك سنتناول هذا
الجانب
الانساني ايضا كذلك
بعد قليل اذا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا وفي مستجدات الوضع الصحي اعلنت وزاره
الصحه السودانيه عن تعدرها استقبال المرضى
في مركز غسل الكلوي في
مستشفى النو توقف الخدمات ايضا وتوقف
الخدمه ايضا كذلك في الصحه قالت بانها
تعاني من نقص الكوادر العامله في المركز
وتكدس المرضى فيه كما دعت الكوادر الطبيه
القريبه من مركز النوب العملي فيه لمساعده
المرضى ناشدت كذلك المتطوعين واهالي
المرضى بتوفير المسكن والحوافز الاستقبال
المرضى وذلك في ظل غياب المسؤولين في
وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه وزاره الصحه في
ولايه الخرطوم وافاد موقع رصد ان السودان
يعاني انقطاع شبه كامل لخدمه الانترنت مع
دخول المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع اسبوعها الثاني قالت منظمه
بلوكس ومقرها لندن التي تعنى برص الوصول
الى شبكه الانترنت في العالم ان بيانات
الشبكه تظهر انهيار شبهه كامل للاتصال
بالانترنت في السودان حيث تبلغ نسبه
الاتصال الوطني حاليا 2% مقارنه
بالمستويات العاديه وتعليقا على الوضع
الانساني ينضم الينا من لندن مدير الوكاله
الدوليه للتنميه والعون الانساني الصادق
محمد احمد سيد الصادق مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه اريد ان اسال عن الوضع السوداني
الانساني كيف يمكن تقييمه في اليوم التاسع
لهذه الاشتباكات
مرحبا بكم الوضع الانساني يزداد سوءا يؤمن
عن يوم
الاوضاع اصبحت معتقد الناس وصلت الى مراحل
بعيده ولكن دعني اعلق على الاحداث ايضا
الماساويه التي تطورت
البارحه واليوم من استهداف للمصانع التي
تنتج على الاقل كان هناك انتاج لبعض
المواد الغذائيه وبعض المستلزمات الطبيه
محليا ولكن تم استهدافها اصلا بواسطه
الدعم السريع التي تقوم الان بتدمير ممنهج
للبيئه التحتيه هذه مليشات التي ارجو ان
اوضح للمشاهد العربي
[موسيقى]
ولكن يجب ان يعلم ان المواطن المشاهد
العربي يجب ان يعلم ان الجيش الان الجيش
القومي السوداني الباسل يخوض الان معركه
الكرامه ضد هذه الميليشيات هذه الميليشيات
التي نكونها الرئيسي عباره عن ميليشيات من
دول اجنبيه دول تشاد والنيجر ومالي
وافريقيا الوسطى هذه
وحتى عائله نفسها هي عائله تشاديه نجحت
الى السودان عام 1990 هذه معلومه معروفه
لجميع الشعب السوداني لذلك هم يقومون الان
بتدمير ممنهج جلبين التحتيه يقومون بقتل
المواطن السوداني واعتقد ان الجيش الان
يمثل كل اطياف الشعب السوداني الذي يخوض
معركه نيابه عنه لاستعاده الكرامه هذه
معركه غسل العار عن عن السودان والتي تسبب
فيها النظام السابق بجلب هذه الميليشيا
المخربه المليشيا الاجنبيه اظن منه النظام
السابقا يظن انه استحمي النظام من
الانتهاء ولكن للاسف اصبحت وبالا على
السودان واصبحت عبئا الان
الشعب السوداني سيد الصادق نحن نريد
الحديث هنا عن الوضع الانساني والوضع
الصحي لا نريد ان ان ندخل طبعا في الوضع
ربما العسكري او السياسي او هذا النزاع
بين طرفي هذه الازمه نحن نريد ان نتحدث عن
ما خلفته هذه الازمه من تبعات صحيه
وانسانيه ونزوح ايضا كذلك نريد ان نركز
معك في هذا الجانب الذي انت متخصص فيه
بشكل دقيق سيدي الصادق اريد ان اسال كذلك
عن عن المستشفيات اذا سمحت لي في الخرطوم
في الفاشر في كذلك النيل الازرق في ايضا
كذلك
في دارفور في
الخرطوم ايضا بحري في الابيض ايضا حتى
كذلك التي تشهد حركه نزوح كبيره من
الخرطوم اليها هل لديكم تقييمات او معرفه
بالاوضاع في هذه المستشفيات
اولا واخيرا انا او قبل كل شيء مواطن
سوداني ودعني اكمل رجاء هذه النقطه التي
يجب ان نوضحها على انها ناطق باسم هذه
الميليشيا على قناتكم قبل قليل يقول انهم
يريدون استعاده الديمقراطيه وتسليم الحكم
الى حكومه مدنيه هذه كلمه حق اريد بها
باطل وهذه يتصدقون بها يغازلون بها
الغرب فيكسبو
ه ولكن لا هم عائله نقلوا تبحث عن حكم
السودان وتريد ان تحكم السودان غصبا عن
وبالرغم عن المواطن السوداني الذي لا يريد
هذه الميليشيا ويعرفه جميعا يعرفون انها
مليشه اجنبيه تنفذ اجندات اقليميه واجندات
خاصه بها هذه يجب ان تتضح للمواطن
السوداني المواطن العربي يجب ان يعلم هذه
المعلومات ويعلم ان الجيش
المواطن السوداني الان يقف في خندق واحد
مع الجيش واذا اعلنت التعبئه العامه جميع
المواطنين السودانيه من الشرفاء سيحملون
السلاح ضد هذه الميليشيا ويجب على المجتمع
الدولي ان يقف مع الحكومه السودانيه وان
يقف مع الجيش السوداني لانه الان اذا قامت
اي ميليشيات بالتمرد على جيش قومي ستقف مع
الجيش القومي مع الحكومه المركزيه ضد هذه
ولكن في حاله السودان اطماع اجنبيه
ولانه يقفون الان
جيشه العميل المخربه هذه المريشه التي
تتكون من المكون الدول الجوار الافريقيه
فقط يعني اريد فقط ان يعني اولا انا احترم
رايك
الشخصي وما تريد ان تقوله لا امنعك من اي
راي واعرف بانك مواطن سوداني وبانك شخص
يعني تتحدث عن رايك عن ما يجول ايضا في
خاطرك عن تقييمك ايضا حتى للوضع لكنني انا
اردت السؤال فقط عن الوضع الانساني والصحي
لان هذا شق لم اتناوله في هذه
الساعه واردت ان اتناوله معك لانك خبير
ومدير الوكاله الدوليه للتنميه والعون
الانساني ايضا
كذلك واردت ان تتحدث فيه ولم امنعك طبعا
من الحديث او عن التعبير عن رايك فيما
يحدث بشكل سياسي او او عسكري
شكرا جزيلا سوف اجيبك على هذا السؤال ولكن
اعلم انني غالبيه السودانيين هذا هو رايهم
سوف اعود الى سؤالك ولكن الوضع الصحي سيء
جدا هذا هو ما يثير الان الحزن والاسف
الواحد يتاسف على ما يجري الان في وطنه
ويتاسف على هذه المعاناه الكبيره التي
يعانيها المرضى انتم تفضلتم الخبر السابق
ان حتى مرض الفجر الكلوي الان لا يستطيعون
الحصول على العلاج اللازم وعمل عمليه
جلسات الغسيل بسبب هذه الاوضاع السيئه
لانه معظم المستشفيات الان تحولت الى
اقسام طوارئ فقط تقدم
العلاج للجرحى من هذه العمليات على الارض
هناك نقص كبير جدا ونقص حاد ان لم يكن
اوشك على الانتهاء لهذه المعينات الطبيه
في معظم المستشفيات في جميع انحاء السودان
بسبب نقص الامدادات ايضا هناك
اشكال كبير جدا في توفير المواد الغذائيه
والمياه حتى مياه الشرب الصالحه للشرب
اصبحت الان المواطن اصبح يعاني منها هذا
ما يثير للاسف الان ايضا نخشى ان يكون
هناك كارثه بيئيه محتمله من جراء انتشار
الجثث على الشوارع وعدم انتشال هذه الجثث
نامل ان يكون هناك انفراج عاجل للازمه
خلال الايام القادمه بان تكون هناك سيطره
للقوات المسلحه على الارض على المناطق
المختلفه المتضرره حتى تقوم المنظمات
الوطنيه والمنظمات
الاجنبيه ايضا بعملها في امداد المحتاجين
الى ذلك الهلال الاحمر السوداني يقوم بعمل
كبير الان على الارض رقم الوضع السيء
والوضع الحرج والخطر وايضا بتنسيق الشؤون
الاجتماعيه نحن علمنا انهم ينشا غرفه
لغرفه متابعه لمحاوله انتشار انتشار الجثث
من الشوارع مبدئيا حتى يتم تفادي هذه
الكارثه البيئيه المحتمله طيب
اريد ان اسال عن المنظمات الاجنبيه وحتى
المنظمات الانسانيه او حتى الصحيه جميعها
علقت العمل في السودان هناك من غادر وهناك
من يختبئ الان من هذا الوضع الحاصل وينتظر
الاجلاء كيف سيؤثر تعليق عمل هذه المنظمات
على الشق الانساني وعلى الصحي ايضا وكذلك
على ايصال حتى المساعدات الى هذه
المستشفيات والى المتضررين سواء من هذه
الاشتباكات او من كانوا يعانون من امراض
قبل هذه الازمه وكانوا موجودين داخل هذه
المستشفيات سيد الصادق
بكل تاكيد التاثير كبير جدا لتعليق عمل
هذه المنظمات هذه المنظمات بلا حدود
ومنظمه الغذاء برنامج الغذاء العالمي
وغيرها منظمات كانت تقوم على الاقل
بسد الفجوه وسد النقص في احتياجاتها معظم
المستشفيات واحتياجات
المتضررين في بعض الاماكن وتعليق عملها
ايضا هذا ما نتحدث عنه تعليق عملها جاء
بعد اعتداء من مليشيات الدعم السريع على
هذه المنظمات برنامج الغذاء العالمي فقد
ثلاث موظفين قبل ايام وهذا كان السبب
الرئيسي بتعليق عمله كذلك
البعثات الدبلوماسيه الان التي تشاهدون
اجزاء رعاياها وايجاء موظفين بعثات
الدبلوماسيه كلها لا تسمع ان هناك طرف
ثالث وطرف رابع لا لا يوجد طرف ثالث ضيفكم
من القاهره الذي علق بان هناك طرف ثالث لا
يوجد طرف ثالث فقط هي قوات المسلحه
والوقات المسلحه تقوم بحمايه هذه البعثات
بالمسؤوليتها الدستوريه ولكن الدعم السريع
تعتقد انه باعتدائها على البعسات
الدبلوماسيه تعتقد انها وعلى المنظمات
التوعيه الدوليه تعتقد انها تحرج الحكومه
وتضعها في خانه المعتدي ولكن هذا يتضح
ومعروف جدا ليه حتى للقوات الدول الخارجيه
الدول العالم جميعا تعرف
ان قائدها مطلوب لدى محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه بتهم بتهم جرائم حرب
وسوف يسلم الى الجنائيه اعتقد اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على المشاركه معي من لندن مدير
الوكاله الدوليه للتنميه والعونه الانساني
الصادق محمد احمد شكرا جزيلا لك اذا نتابع
واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام هذا الفيديو
المتداول
لهجوم على سجن كوبر هذا السجن الذي يتواجد
فيه الرئيس السوداني المعزول عمر
البشير وكانت طبعا قد شهدت
السودان الخرطوم تحديدا هجوما اخر لاطلاق
سراح بعض من موجودين في سجن الهدى كما
طبعا انتشرت الاخبار والانباء ايضا كذلك
وحتى الفيديوهات على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هذا مقطع متداول ايضا اخر لهجوم
على سجن كوبر بالخرطوم هناك انباء عن هروب
سجناء من داخل هذا السجن سجن كوبر وكما
ذكرنا وهو السجن الذي يتواجد به الرئيس
المعزول عمر البشير وكذلك ايضا بعض
السياسيين
وفنون النظام السوداني السابق الموجودين
داخل هذا
السجن سجن كوبر اذا هذا مقطع متداول لهجوم
على سجن كوبر كما ذكرنا قبل قليل كان هناك
هجوم اخر يوم امس على سجن الهدى واطلاق
سراح الكثير من المسجونين ومن وصفوا
بالمجرمين داخل هذا السجن سجن الهدى وكذلك
ايضا سجون اخرى مهاجمه ايضا حتى الحراسات
الامنيه التي كانت يعني بالقرب من هذا
او في محيط هذا السجن كانت تحرس ايضا كذلك
هذا السجن مراكز الشرطه القريبه من السجن
كما ذكر امس رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان
وهذا امتداد لما حدث منذ يوم امس مقطع
المتداول للهجوم على سجن كوبر بالخرطوم
والانباع عن هروب سجناء لا تزال الصور
التي تاتي مشاهدينا من العاصمه الخرطوم
كما نشاهد اعلى الشاشه الصور المباشره من
العاص مه الخرطوم لاعمده كثيفه من الدخان
وهي تغطي سماء العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
اعود الى الرياض ومن هناك الى ضيفي الذي
كنت قد بدات معه في منتصف هذه النشره
الحوار محمود لعوته الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني مرحبا بك معي من جديد اريد ان
تعلق على الفيديو قبل قليل الذي تم تداوله
في الاوساط السودانيه وعرضناه قبل قليل
على شاشه العربيه لهجوم على سجن كوبر هناك
انباع عن هروب سجناء هل يمكن ان يكون
الرئيس
المعزول عمر البشير من ضمن من هربوا من
هذا السجن
وطبعا انا ما شفت الفيديو لانه انا بتكلم
معك وفي غرفه مغلقه يعني ما فيها تلفزيون
لكن بس مع الاصوات يعني في اصوات تكبير
يعني
لكن خليني ابدا معك يا اخي هو اساسا مساله
السجون دي بدت سلسله من الهدى وامس قوات
الدعم السريع بكل اسف اطلقت اكثر من 6,000
سجين في سجين كوبر وهؤلاء يتوجهوا الى
منطقه بشكل النيل يحملون العصي والسيخ
يعني هذا خطوره كبيره وايضا خرجت تم برضو
يعني اطلاق
سينات من سجن ام درمان للنساء
وخرجوا بحجه انه هؤلاء ليس لديهم ما
ياكلونه يعني انا اعتقد هذه بدايه الفوضى
الخلابه وهذه في الخرطوم وبالتالي مع
فاكهه هؤلاء المجرمين الذين كانوا طبعا هم
حكم عليهم باحكام قضائيه بالتالي يعتبروا
مجرمين واذا خرجوا من الشوارع ان اعتقد
سوف تزداد الجريمه اكثر
ويمكن
المواطنين الان الموجودين المحبوسين في في
المنازل سوف يتعرضون لسرقات وجرائم قتل
بشكل فظي يعني اريد ان اسال عن السيناريو
يعني اطلاقه من السجون هل هو بهدف هل هو
بهدف
اسمعني فقط ان اكمل سؤالي اذا سمحت سيد
محمود
هل هل هو بهدف ان يقاتلوا الى الى جانب اي
من الطرفين وان كانت قوه الدعم السريع ام
لاشغال القوات الحكوميه يعني في العاصمه
الخرطوم بعدد اعطيك معلومه بعد ما تم يعني
قتله مدير سيجنا الهدى في ام درمان
القوات الدعم السريع اخذت نحو عشرين مجرم
محكوم عليهم بالاعدام لماذا اخذتهم
تخدمون في في اعمال انتحاريه في مسائل
اقتحاميه يعني هذا شيء فقط انا اريد ان
اشير الى هذا العاجل اسفل الشاشه اذا سمحت
للسيد محمود مصادر العربيه تؤكد بان
السجناء السياسيين في سجن كوبر لا يزال
قيد الاحتجاز اذا مصادر العربيه الان تقول
بان السجناء السياسيين في سجن كوبر لا
يزال قيد الاحتجاز
نعيد التذكير طبعا هذا الفيديو المتداول
الان على شاشه العربيه كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
هو لهجوم على سجن كوبر بالخرطوم اثناء هذه
الاشتباكات انباع عن هروب سجناء لكن مصادر
العربيه تؤكد بان السجناء السياسيين
الموجودين في سجن كوبر لا يزالون قيد
الاحتجاز من بين هؤلاء السجناء طبعا كما
ذكرنا قبل قليل الرئيس السوداني المعزول
عمر البشير وعدد من يعني فلول النظام
السابق اذن الكثير من سجناء سجن كوبر تم
اطلاق السراحهم اعود مره اخرى اليك السيد
محمود يعني في ظل هذا الوضع السجناء
الموجودون داخل هذه السجون سواء في الهدى
في كوبر في ام درمان
لا احد يستطيع اولا ان يؤمنهم ان يؤمن لهم
الغذاء وايضا كذلك الماكل المشرب او
الاهتمام باوضاع السجون ومن هم داخل هذه
السجون فما الذي كان يجب ان ان تفعله سواء
ان يفعله الجيش او قوات الدعم السريع
للتعامل مع هذا الوضع في ظل هذه
الاشتباكات المحتدمه والوضع الانساني
الصعب في السودان
وطبعا يعني في في ظل الوضع الحالي لا يمكن
تامين حراسه قويه على هذه
المواقع يقصد السجون لانه عندها هي قوات
خاصه قوات السجود وطبعا قوات السجون في
هذه الاوضاع والظروف لا تستطيع ان تعمل او
تؤدي عملها بشكل موطوق في ظل وجود جنود
مدجاجين بالسلاح الثقيل يعني فاكيد انه
قوات السجون حتى لو هجموا عليهم من يعني
قوات منفلته لا يستطيعون مواجهه هذه او
تامين حراسه مشدده على تلك السجود
وبالتالي اعتقد انه هذا الذي يقتحم السجون
انا اعتقد عنده هدف وراه قصد انه زياده
رقعت او دائره الفوضى
[موسيقى]
حتى بالذات يعني لا لا تجعل بالذات القوات
المسلحه
تركب بمطاردتها لقوات او كتيبه الدعم
السريعه هذا التحليلي المنطقي انا ليس ليس
عسكريا ولكن تحليل المنطقي وليست وليست
معلومات لكن من المستفيد من هذه الفوضى
بشكل يعني
الاقرب حسب تحليل قوات الدعم السريع لانه
تنعكس عليها ميدانيا
القوات المسلحه لهم يعني هذا السبب يعني
ممكن يستخدموا هذه هؤلاء السجناء دروع
بشريه وارد انا دائما
ممكن يستخدمون اكيد في كل العمليات
العسكريه الموجوده
[موسيقى]
يعني يقوم باحتقام
السجناء وقتلهم وفتح الابواب واطلاق سراح
السجن هذا من ناحيه
طيب بالنسبه للسجناء السياسيين الان
المصادر العربيه تؤكد بانهم لا يزالون قيد
الاحتجاز انت تتحدث قبل قليل بانه لا يمكن
تامين مثلا حراسه شديده او حراسه كبيره
بسبب التوترات النزاعات ايضا
انه الحراسه في في
السجن تاريخي معروف بتكون اشد من من اي
حراسه ثانيه باي شيء ثاني لانه هذول
يختلفون هذول هذول سجناء سياسيين وانت
تعرف انه اعتقد انه بيزيدوا عليهم الحراسه
انا اعتقد حسب معلوماتي السجن كوبر اعتقد
كان
مكلف به يعني قوات الدعم السريع بس ما
اعرف اللي حصل شنو يعني اخيرا ولكن طبعا
انا عايز اعلق على الفيديو طبعا في بعض
الاحيان في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اذا
كان مصدر من اين مصدر هذه الفيديو اذا كان
من مصدر مواقع التواصل اجتماع اعتقد انه
يكون هذا الغرض منه
يعني وضع الناس امام الامر الواقع بانه
اكيد زي ما هناك قوات اقتحمت
سجون مختلفه ممكن المره المره القادمه سوف
يكون الاحتقام على اعتقد الذين يحترمون
على طبعا الناس منتميين لحزب المؤتمر
الوطني السابق انا اعتقد هذا
هذا احتمالات كبيره جدا لانهم
يريدون سياسيين من الموجودين في في الصين
وعلى راسهم الرئيس عمر البشير يعني
انا
اعتقد اعتقد فيه اشاره واضحه انه المره
القادمه لاحق سيكون في شيء كوبر
السريع ولا القوات المسلحه سوف تحطيهم لكن
هنالك جماعات هو فقط يعني تاكيد المؤكد
المصادر مصادرنا في العربيه تؤكد بان هناك
سجناء تم اطلاق سراحهم من سجن كوبر ليس
بينهم اي سجين
سياسي على كل حال انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على المشاركه معي من الرياض محمود لعوته
الكاتب الصحفي السوداني
الان مشاهدينا الى ابرز الاخبار الدوليه
الاخرى وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه التام
الرئيس الاوكراني الرئيس الروسي بانه
يقاتل من اجل حياته وليس من اجل روسيا على
حد تعبيره
لا استطيع بالتاكيد ان اصف الوضع بانه جيد
لكننا نكافح نحن اقوى مما كنا عليه قبل
عام لقد حررنا بعض اراضينا والبلد متحد من
اجل النصر بوتين سيفقد ما ذهب اليه بهذا
العدوان سوف يفقد ثقه شعبه في ان الدول
المجاوره لروسيا هي نفسها تماما او اسوا
سيرى الجميع كيف تتطور دول خارج النفوذ
الروسيه بوتين يقاتل من اجل حياته في
اوكرانيا انه لا يقاتل حتى من اجل روسيا
ولا من اجل لغته الروسيه
وابدا الرئيس الاوكرانيه عدم احترامه
لاتفاقيات مسك مضيفا ان الهدف منها لم يكن
لانهاء الحرب
حكومتنا لم توقع على اتفاقيات منسك انا لم
اوقعها كرئيس لقد وقعوها قبلي انها
الحقيقه في رايي اتفاقيات ليست عمليه
لانهاء الحرب الجميع بحاجه الى فهم هذا
لقد كانت عمليه تحديد المكان الذي توقفت
فيه روسيا احتلت شبه جزيره القرم وضمتها
دون قتال للاسف لم تقاتل اوكرانيا من اجل
القرم بعد ذلك استولت على جزء من دومباس
بدات الحرب وبدا الموت وفي تلك اللحظه
تعرفون وقعت المجموعه الرباعيه المكونه من
فرنسا والمانيا وروسيا واوكرانيا اتفاقيات
مينسك لوضع خطه الاجراءات لانهاء الحرب
هذه الحرب على الرغم من انه لم يطلق عليها
احد في ذلك الوقت حربا
ان مال يقل عن خمسه صواريخ روسيه اصابت
مدينه خاركب شرق اوكرانيا والمناطق
المحيطه بها حيث كتب حاكم المنطقه على
تطبيق تيليجرام ان صاروخا اصاب منزلا في
احدى القرى جنوب المدينه بينما تسبب صاروخ
اخر في اندلاع حريق كبير في المدينه نفسها
والحق بعض الاضرار في مباني المدنيه
اصدر وزراء زراعه الدول الاعضاء في مجموعه
السبع بيانا حول اتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود حيث ابدو من خلاله عن
تاييدهم بتمديد الاتفاق بشده والتنفيذ
الكامل والتوسع في مبادره تصدير الحبوب
عبر البحر الاسود
الوزراء استنكروا في البيان محاولات روسيا
في استخدام الغذائي كاداه لزعزعه
الاستقرار والاكراه الجيوسي
انتاج جولتنا الاخباريه وايضا معها تنتهي
هذه الساعه الاخباريه العاجله والمباشره
على شاشه العربيه والتي تناولنا فيها اخر
تطورات المشهد في السودان التغطيه مستمره
دائما على العربيه والان الى زميل ميسون
عزام تفضلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات